this is cereth registered nurse re and
calm and in this video I want to
demonstrate how to assess the eyes now
if you would like to watch a complete
head-to-toe nursing assessment you can
access here in the card or in the
YouTube description below a link to the
video that will show you how to do that
now for this skill what you want to do
is you'll want to provide privacy to the
patient wash your hands and tell them
what you were doing and equipment you
will need for this is a pin light so
let's get started we're going to inspect
the eyes first and we're looking at
several things we're looking at the
eyelid we're looking at the sclera which
is the white of the eyes we're looking
at the iris we're looking at the pupil
and we're looking at the conjunctiva so
you shouldn't see any swelling of the
eyelids you should see that the sclera
is Y and shiny it shouldn't be yellow
like in jaundice and the conjunctiva
when you pull down the lower lid have
the patient look up it should be nice
and pink it shouldn't be red you
shouldn't see any drainage or anything
like that and look at the eyes how do
they set in the eye socket is are they
equal for instance is there any
strabismus is there a cross eye where
one eye turns in more turns out or up or
down and these eyes are normal there's
no strabismus next you want to look at
anisocoria where you have where one
pupil would be smaller than the other
people are they equal in size normal
pupils should be 3 to 5 millimeters in
their measurement and here his are about
a 3 and they are equal next what we're
gonna do is we're going to assess some
cranial nerves we're gonna be looking at
cranial nerve three which is ocular
motor for troq Euler and then 6 which is
abducens and we're gonna do several
tests to check their function the first
one what we're gonna do is we're gonna
be looking for any involuntary shaking
of the eye called nystagmus and how
we're gonna do that was we're gonna take
our pin line we're gonna hold it about
12 to 14 inches away from the patient's
nose and then what I want you to do
is keep your head still don't move your
head and just use your eyes to watch
where I move the pin line and as you're
doing this you're going to do you're
going to perform it in the six cardinal
fields of gaze and you're just going to
move it and you're looking for any
involuntary shaking of the eyes so here
we go
next we're going to see how reactive the
pupils are to lie and to do that we're
going to dim the lights a little bit and
we're gonna have the patients stare off
at a distant object that helps dilate
those pupils and then we're going to
shine using our pin line in at the side
and we're gonna see how that pupil
response is she constrict and then on
the other side it should constrict as
well so say their baseline pupil size
was like three millimeters it should go
down to one milliliter and it should
happen on both sides okay so being stare
off at that object rod on the wall over
there for me okay and that dilates the
pupils and we're just going to shine
light in at this side okay constrict
constrict okay I'm dilate again and then
go over to the other side do the same
again and they both constricted and
equal size next what we're gonna do is
we're gonna check for accomodation and
how we do that is we turn the lights
back on we just previously had them
dimmed but we now make it light again
we're gonna have him stare off at a
distant object that helps dilate the
pupils and we're going to take a pin
light you can use a pin light finger and
you're just going to slowly move it
inward to the nose and what you're
looking for is that those pupils
constrict they accommodate and the eyes
cross while looking at the pin line so
here we go stare off in the distance
please and I don't want you to move your
head or anything just keep it real still
and just follow this pin light okay
ready
okay so now we can document because we
just checked all of the things with the
eyes we can document that the pupils are
equal round reactive to lie in the
accommodate so that's where that acronym
perrla comes into play okay so that
wraps up how to assess the eyes and
don't forget to check out that video on
how to perform a complete head-to-toe
nursing assessment thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos